dude what the [ __ ] is up with area 51
first of all are there 50 other areas
it's a bad stand up dude and what's it
do very 51 what's it like there's 50
other areas just so many new audience
yes alright well you know I'm just
saying it'll more than that yes okay
okay well anyway what's going on in the
news that's what's going on in the new
listen ban dude so so uh I [ __ ] area
51 about how there's like 2.2 million
people that however many through many
people's I want to storm the [ __ ]
thing they can't they can't stop us all
hey dude
yes they can they can't stop us dude you
know how many they can of you they can
stop do you know how many of you they
can stop all of you dude I can't and
that that is the definition of first to
go anybody that goes I don't care if
you're a [ __ ] well-to-do person I
don't care what race you are I don't
care how smart you are I don't care if
you're helping the world I don't care
what you do barring you cure cancer if
you show up to raid area 51 I don't feel
bad if you get mowed down dude I mean
dude are you kidding me the people at
area 51 so I don't know if you know this
but there's like a petition out there I
was like hey we all want to raid area 51
they can't stop us all sign up and we're
gonna all go at some point which I hope
is a joke I rub but I don't know anymore
these days it's his Facebook event right
1.5 right now they can't stop all of us
hosted by [ __ ] posting because I'm in
shambles okay get a more professional
name anyway we will all meet up at the
area 51 alien Center tourist attraction
and coordinate our entry I have a plan
before that if we now route or run we
can move faster than their bullets okay
well he can't so I think this guy
started as a joke obviously but
like there are people that are for sure
taking this seriously because there are
too many people now people that area 51
are reading this and they're loading
their weapons and they can't wait dude
they can't wait bro they can't wait hey
do you mind give me that water
Thanks there's they've been waiting for
this dude they're just sitting there
like pretending I mean if there is
anything about aliens at area 51 like
there just been they've just been
waiting is this real this is real Naruto
running K they're not Naruto running the
regular jogging with their hands behind
their [ __ ] so it's all good I mean
they're barely jogging so anyway so
anyway they're waiting and then when
they start dude if I was at area 51 and
they started Neruda running first of all
we're gonna start from you got to start
from really far away because their
weapons go real far because their guns
they also have [ __ ] other things
other than guns if there really are
aliens there then they are checking out
the alien technology they're just gonna
[ __ ] boom like there's gonna be one
loud boom and people just gonna lose
their lists disintegrates gonna be like
the end of end Avengers or whatever the
[ __ ] end game but yeah Naruto run all
you want dude those [ __ ] are in
there they're ready with their turrets
bro and they'll get all of you and
they'll just [ __ ] load them up and it
won't even last that long and that's it
and somebody will be done I'll be like
weeks right no run and then I will be in
the front Joe like you know I will be in
the back like I was playing I didn't
really want to go I just can't believe
that also Naruto running what we're
looking at Naruto running now on the on
I mean dude it's so [ __ ] to run with
your hands behind your back like that
like I know this Japanese [ __ ] they're
trying to be like this is this [ __ ]
and in a way it kind of is but it's so
[ __ ] to run like that dude Wow
to run just like this mm-hmm it's like
you're trying to get away from your
mommy bro that's not no rutile running
mommy dude Wow you know what I really
want to see a [ __ ] 50 year old Naruto
run with a belly imagine the Rooter
running and falling down but had taken
one of those long fall downs my favorite
falling downs are when people here's the
deal dude if you're gonna fall down just
[ __ ] fall right that's the way to do
it but if you're gonna fall down and you
keep trying and the momentum keeps
bringing you over you're like whoa I
almost got I got got got and it takes
more than a second or two bro you win
the cebiche board